alors vous c'est incroyable à vous êtes
de plus en plus aimés de plus en plus
considérée au fil des ans
alors maintenant on dit du bien de vous
dans télérama dans les cahiers du cinéma
les inrockuptibles c'est bien vous avez
eu un césar d'honneur vous avez eu quand
même là la seule standing ovation de la
soirée c'est oui c'était sympathique
oui ça m'a fait plus plaisir même
peut-être que le césar c'était la la la
la salle qui c'est qui était debout ce
sera très émouvant oui où vous avez dit
ce soir là je suis heureux de paraître
devant mes pairs moi qui n'ai jamais été
autre chose qu'un un père déjà une très
belle phrase et ensuite c'est aller voir
votre médecin pour savoir si je suis
pour longtemps maintenant un césar
d'honneur jeudi un petit césar avant la
route et comment ça va ça va très bien
c'est pas un peu tard pour vous la
semaine
non je peux encore assumer ce
détachement aux jambes ça va non non ce
cas c'est qu'après j'ai besoin d'un
petit et chaud en tous les cas peuvent
dans si vous avez vraiment créer un
personnage effectivement comme pierre
richard était un personnage et c'est
yves robert vous qui vous a dit ça et
vous a dit impose ton univers et ton
personnage créé ton cinéma
ouais il m'avait dit je m'en suis
toujours je me souviens même veulent du
lieu et de l'endroit
c'est la même chose je me suis dit
m'avait dit on nous marchions le long
d'une route du nord une voie ferrée et
m'a dit pire tu n'es pas un acteur tient
personnage ouais je l'avais à moitié
bien pris parce que je me suis mes
pensées l'acteur j'ai compris que
j'étais plus un personnage qu'un acteur
et c'est pour ça que je me suis toujours
senti un peu bord cadre de la famille
des acteurs
alors j'ai également sur scène avec
détournement de mémoire d'ailleurs le 27
mars au casino de paris
il ya beaucoup de rires dans ce
spectacle mais beaucoup d'émotion aussi
des choses insoupçonnées chez vous en
voyez moi aussi d'ailleurs j'étais
pareil je soupçonnais pas ça ouais non
mais c'est vrai oui je sais pas mais
évidemment je joué sur du velours parce
que je parle de souvenirs à une des
grands acteurs avec lesquels j'ai pu
travailler
la plupart des ces souvenirs sont
extrêmement drôle parce que blier carmet
son décès fait des phénomènes et puis
bien sûr il en est resté quelques
souvenirs très émouvant notamment sur
jean et sur bernard et
le sort des gens que les gens aiment
donc quand j'en parle que cette émotion
est finalement gelée tous les soirs j'ai
jamais autant penser à acquérir autant
de ma vie qu'un quart mais oubliée
puisque tous les soirs ils vivent avec
moi bon ben c'est émouvant oui mais je
pensais pas ça moi je pensais faire rire
ça fait ouvrir beaucoup si j'ai quand
même des tas d'anecdotes incroyable il y
en a une qui est incroyable c'est
mireille darc la première fois que vous
tournez avec elle est nue basta dire
qu'elle devait s'arranger un mois dans
toute nue et moi j'ai des lits et elle
devait avancer vers moi elle a dit pire
tu me regarde dans les yeux si tu tu
incites on regarde descend je t'en fous
une baffe tout ce que j'imaginais pour
trouver un bon prétexte pour baisser les
yeux et d'éternuer il ya des trucs
invraisemblables aussi ses quinze jours
par exemple vous jouez macbeth et vous
vous endormez sur scène mais c'est vrai
ça c'est vrai et c'est vrai que le
système à l'époque c'était de changer
des décors s'il n'y avait pas de rideaux
il y avait le noir les figurants en été
20 25
non nous aurons s'agiter pour changer
les décors et leurs maîtres et remettre
les décors restent une suivante dans un
minimum de temps pour pas et moi je me
suis endormi quand dans l'acte précédent
si on m'a tuer je suis mort et je me
suis endormi et j'ai rien vu jusqu'ici
la suite je surveillais aux pieds nus de
la reine tout mon problème était de
savoir comment j'allais sortir soit je
me levais naturellement chez bourg
madame
ça me semblait pas vraiment soit je
restais coucher comme une carpette
je me disais après tout elle et les
divers ont bien des peaux de tigres pour
exposer leurs pieds la nique aux soldats
quoi c'était soit je rampe et doucement
vers la sortie et c'est la troisième que
j'ai choisi je ne suis pas pour près sur
ce soit les d'ailleurs c'est la pire
parce que c'est grand le thème paix
qu'on m'a vu on a vu
au ralenti